aside from buying a house going to
University is probably the biggest
investment decision you'll face in your
entire life at the end of the day going
to college should be an economic
decision not an emotional decision in
this free course freeco Camp founder
Quincy Larson will help you decide how
to plan for college he'll explain how
U.S Higher Education Works how the labor
market works and will provide some
strategies for minimizing your costs at
the end of the day he wants to help you
maximize your return on investment
Quincy recently published a free
full-length book about developer careers
and college is the number one thing
people ask him about by the way people
also ask him a lot about chat gbt and
whether they still need to learn to code
spoiler alert his answer is yes
so grab your notebook or crack open your
text editor because Quincy's gonna fire
a lot of data at you from his Decades of
working in adult education Quincy pulls
no punches and has no mercy when talking
about the U.S University system the
student debt epidemic and the student
visa system that leaves so many bright
people unable to get a U.S degree but
rest assured he has tons of practical
tips that your college counselor
probably never told you about at the end
of the day Quincy wants the same thing
for you that your family wants for you
to earn a good living and have a ton of
career options if you learned something
from this course be sure to send it to a
friend or family member who's planning
for college
hey I'm Quincy Larson teacher and
founder of freecodecamp.org
and today we're going to be asking the
very timely question
is college still worth it and I'm going
to be arguing that in most cases yes it
is still worth it you're going to hear
all this hype around oh College who
needs College anymore I'm going to argue
from
numbers that college is still incredibly
useful it's still incredibly worth it
I'm also going to be talking about lots
of situations where I don't think it's
worth it and I'm going to be talking
about some strategies that you can use
to produce student debt reduce the
capital outlay that this giant four-year
education can
represent for many people who are
learning so let's Dive In
what about return on investment
the first thing you should consider
about education is this is an economic
decision you may have aspirational
reasons why you want to go to college
maybe you're the first person in your
family lineage to ever go and get a
degree and that can be a very proud
moment uh maybe you have served in the
armed forces and you essentially have
this free way to go to university in the
sense that you've got the GI bill that's
going to pay for a lot of your higher
education you still should think about
things in terms of economics and you
should still think about it in terms of
how much money is going to cost and
ultimately how much is going to affect
your earning potential we're going to
think about this in terms of return
on investment Roi you may have heard
that acronym before there are other ways
of course you can think about this for
example if you're a big Finance person
you might think in terms of Net Present
Value which will factor in the time
value of money and that's a very real
consideration as well because money
today is worth a lot more than money in
the future not just because of inflation
but because of opportunity to invest
that money so you might instead of going
to University and spending uh the
equivalent of forty thousand dollars on
four years of in-state tuition you might
want to just take that forty thousand
dollars if you have it in cash now and
just put it in uh some sort of
investment vehicle probably like an
index fund and just let it accumulate
over time right that might be a rational
thing to do depending on the ROI that
you're looking at now in order to figure
out what the ROI is we want to figure
out how much money you're earning right
now just with your current skills
you can probably go out and get a job as
a janitor and make about twelve dollars
an hour in the United States so if you
think about twelve dollars an hour you
multiply that times about 2 000 hours
per year that you're gonna be working
that's about eight hours or that's 40
hours a week times approximately 50
weeks assuming you've got two weeks off
which may or may not be paid I'm just
going to call it
twenty four thousand dollars a year
so let's go ahead and let's think in
terms I'm going to show a fancy chart on
the screen right now this is
approximately how much you can expect to
earn with varying levels of what we'll
call educational attainment so uh if you
went to high school
great congratulations on graduating from
high school you're going to make more
than somebody who didn't go to high
school or didn't finish high school now
getting a general equivalency diploma
GED that's basically the same as going
to high school for most you know
economic considerations if you go to
some college that does technically
increase your earning potential a little
bit but what really helps is not going
to some college not getting an
Associates necessarily but getting the
full bachelor's degree a bachelor's
degree will roughly 2x your expected
annual earnings over what you would get
if you just had a high school diploma so
that is why
you definitely want to consider going to
college depending on how many years of
productive life you have left so let's
say you're uh you know 18 to 25 would be
a traditional student so that's the age
range that most people are that's what
most uh economists and most Educators
would consider to be traditional
University student that probably means
that if you live to be about 80 years
old
which is the life expectancy of most
Americans like women live slightly
longer than men there can be all other
all kinds of different factors like your
income bracket uh family history things
like that that can play into it but
we'll just call the average life
expectancy of an American 80 years old
so you probably have already picked up
on on what I'm talking about so far that
I'm focusing mostly on the United States
that's because I grew up in the United
States I'm an American citizen I have
studied abroad I studied in China for
several years so I I have kind of a
little bit of study abroad perspective
and I have worked extensively with
International students who come from
other countries to study in the United
States so we'll talk about that later
too but I there is going to be a heavy
U.S focus in this course so if you're
going to live to be 80s you're years old
and you're going to work
maybe 40 years after you finish so you
could basically take that uh that 2x
multiplier and you could take the
difference between earning twenty four
thousand dollars a year as a janitor and
earning something like 44
000 as a college graduate and by the way
your janitor income is not going to
necessarily increase steadily over time
it may keep up with inflation but don't
expect to be making like 2x as a janitor
just because you have a whole lot of
janitorial experience however if you're
working as a software engineer you might
be able to make 4X 10x what you made
when you first got out of college as you
gradually progress uh through your
career and accrue more experience accrue
more tacit knowledge of how the industry
Works accrue more skills accrue more
responsibility so that is what I'll say
is you want to be thinking in those
terms
how long you're going to be working and
what the wage differential is going to
be and that will be the best way to
figure out your Roi
how does student debt work
in the United States the way that most
people pay for their education is
through some combination of working
during University some combination of
their parents helping them pay for
school scholarships and of course
student debt and student debt is one of
the most complicated factors in trying
to determine Roi because you have to
repay that student debt and you're not
sure whether you're going to finish
University you're not sure whether your
wage after you finish University is
going to be high enough for you to be
able to repay that debt and I know lots
of people who have I'm not exaggerating
more than a hundred thousand US dollars
worth of student debt and that they have
to repay so with student debt the best
way to think of it is it's additional
risk that you're incurring
risk
so
I said earlier that if you finish
College you're going to basically double
your income
in aggregate now again it does depend on
what you're going to study and we'll get
that we'll get to that in a minute but
the big thing that you need to keep in
mind is student debt is going to be
there whether you finish or not
you're taking a risk when you take out a
student loan you if you study a field
and you can't get a job afterward that's
pretty bad uh maybe you have to be
what's called underemployed and you're
working in Hospitality despite the fact
that you studied uh nursing or something
like that now in practice I think if you
study nursing you'll almost certainly be
able to find a job as a nurse but let's
say hypothetically you study
physics and you can't find a job as a
physicist or in order to get a job as a
physicist you have to go back to school
and get a PhD most of the working
physicists I know have phds we won't get
into graduate school in this course
because I really want to focus on the
decision to get the initial four-year
degree but I will say that a lot of
times you get into a field and there's
what's called
credential inflation
and
well inflation means is basically you
want to work as a librarian oh it's no
longer good enough to have an
undergraduate degree in library science
you need to get a master's degree in
library science and that may sound
absurd why do you need a master's degree
to be a librarian but unfortunately
that's where things are going in a lot
of fields that are more competitive so
uh
the risk the biggest risk is not not
getting a job when you get out because
you have this University degree and any
sort of degree will give you an edge in
the labor market it will increase your
likelihood of getting interviews and
ultimately getting hired for a variety
of different jobs even those jobs that
are not related to your major the
biggest risk is that for some reason you
can't finish life gets in the way you uh
your parents have some sort of accident
and you need to go be their caretaker or
you get pregnant or you have some sort
of
illness like you have experienced
vertigo or any number of different
things that can that can cause you to
have trouble being able to focus and
being able to finish school so if you do
not finish school the debt remains and
you still have to figure out a way to
pay that off and the worst situation you
can find yourself in
is where you've taken a lot of student
debt out and you no longer have the
ability to repay it because you're
earning way below and you you might be
able to go into something called
forbearance where essentially your debt
is deferred to an extent or you're
paying a very small amount as opposed to
the full amount that you're supposed to
pay but when you're doing that your debt
is not getting paid off and in fact it
may actually be getting larger and at
some point you're going to have to
figure out a way to pay off that debt so
here is my humble advice to you
to the extent you can completely avoid
the risk of debt
I've already taken out student debt my
humble advice would be you know do
whatever you can to pay it off as soon
as possible because debt can be an
albatross around your neck you can
really weigh you down and prevent you
from taking the kinds of career risks
that might ultimately bear a whole lot
of fruit when you're a little later in
your career you may have to be focusing
all your time and energy working a
certain job that you don't particularly
like but that pays the bills and you
don't have energy left at the end of the
day to do things like learn the code or
to learn mathematics or to build your
network or to build cool projects and
put them on GitHub that you can
essentially use as portfolio pieces to
help you get a better job later on so
the biggest risk that if you can avoid
debt avoid debt and I'm going to give
you some strategies for how to avoid
getting student debt later
especially
what major should I study
so there are a lot of people out there
who will joke about getting a liberal
arts degree like oh of course you're
poor you've got a liberal arts degree of
course you're poor you studied drama or
you studied music or something like that
I think that that attitude is really not
productive and I know plenty of people
who studied liberal arts that are
working in positions of power in society
I studied liberal arts I'm an under my
undergraduate degree is in Liberal Arts
and I'm running an NGO and have like 35
people reporting to me right so you
could argue that uh those skills are not
immediately useful for getting certain
types of jobs but later in life they
become incredibly useful if you look at
what liberal arts people learn they
learn foreign languages they learn uh
argumentation and debate rhetoric they
learn how to analyze things and how to
write really well and how to present
themselves at a whiteboard like this so
there are a variety of different skills
you'll build if you study liberal arts
but let's face it if you study a field
like computer science you are going to
be vastly better off and I'm going to
put a chart up here that will show
approximately how much more money you
can make as somebody from a purely
economic standpoint how much more money
you can make as a computer science major
than pretty much any other major now one
thing you're going to note here is oh
petroleum engineering maybe I should
study petroleum engineering just for fun
here let's put this petroleum
engineering job uh description into
indeed.com which is a job search engine
I frequently use to show people uh
approximately how much market demand how
many roles there are now this is a very
course measure but it's better than
nothing and we can see that there are
very few jobs for petroleum engineering
those jobs may be higher paid but there
are fewer of them and uh you know I
don't know why petroleum Engineers are
paid marginally more than computer
science Majors but I don't really care
that much because the amount difference
is so small one
thinking about your life the difference
between making eighty thousand dollars
and a hundred thousand dollars is a lot
less of a difference than going from
making 25 000 a year to fifty thousand
dollars right like or even forty five
thousand dollars right a similar to
twenty thousand dollar jump
the reality is like once you have a
certain amount of money every marginal
dollar beyond that still feels good but
it's less vital to your survival so uh I
would say that yes you'll find reports
of people who say oh you know computer
science isn't the highest paid major the
reality is there are vastly more jobs
for computer science Majors than there
are for virtually every other major you
can do like and it's a very well defined
skill set whereas studying Business
Administration less well-defined
if you look at the Fortune 50 CEOs in
the United States as I'm filming
you're going to see that they have a
wide variety
of different Majors many of them studied
liberal arts like I did and then the
most well represented of course being
engineers and if you think about it that
makes sense because what are the biggest
companies in the United States they're
mostly tech companies right and every
company is kind of trying to become a
tech company so it definitely helps to
have somebody with an engineering
knowledge at the helm of that company so
I would strongly recommend studying
computer science I would recommend it
above other stem fields and here's why I
have lots of friends who study Physics I
have lots of friends who studied
chemistry I have lots of friends who
studied life science and
most of them have kind of seen the
writing on the wall that the actual
high-paying jobs are working with
software and they've had to go and learn
to code after school maybe they did some
coding I mean like if you study any stem
field uh science technology engineering
mathematics you are probably going to
take some programming classes but
when you graduate and you look at the
job market you're going to say wow I
really need to learn more programming
you're going to end up on
freecodecamp.org welcome we love having
people who have science backgrounds
further refine their programming skills
and we're happy to help with that but
you may be able to take more programming
more mathematics more more things that
are relevant to the actual Developer
jobs that are out there that are
generally the best jobs in the country
in my opinion that are going to give you
a good combination of flexibility being
able to work remotely career trajectory
you can go all the way up to CEO as a
software engineer whereas like you know
if you study certain Fields there may be
some sort of like area where you cap out
and you have to go get an MBA or
something to continue to proceed
and of course compensation software
Engineers are
they make more money than basically
anybody including people who essentially
go to school to learn how to make money
people who study Finance business
administration things like that right so
that tells you a lot about the value of
computer science another quick note
there are degrees in fields like
Computer Engineering uh I.T and another
one is software engineering now you
would actually think software
engineering would be the best major in
terms of being prepared to work in
software engineering I can't tell you
exactly why because I'm not sure exactly
why but most hiring managers most HR
people are proactively looking for
people who have computer science degrees
and having a degree in software
engineering while it might actually help
you do the job better it may make it
slightly harder for you to find that job
so when in doubt just go with a computer
science degree
what if I'm older
so if you are older
again it comes back into the question of
r o i how many years do you think you're
going to be working
I would say that
um don't underestimate yourself I'm 42 I
feel high energy granted I don't have
any like genetic issues I'm not on
insulin I don't have a lot of things
that may be plaguing people as they get
into their 40s but I do believe that I
can probably work another 20 or 30 years
productively so retirement age in the
United States I believe is 67 so so just
subtract your age from 67 and that's a
rough rubric for how many years you're
going to have left now
if you take that multiplier and double
your income and then you subtract out
the cost of a college education again if
you go to in-state tuition at a
four-year institution it's going to be
about ten thousand dollars a year in
tuition that doesn't include
fees
um and you know when you go to a big
State University you're kind of also
paying for them to maintain the lawn on
the uh the stadium and uh to maintain
the random buildings that you know
provide air conditioning and water and
all the other the physical plant
um you know there are lots of fees
Student Activity fees Library fees
things like that so Factor those in and
then of course the big thing is cost of
living and the thing you need to factor
in is okay I'm going to be spending
approximately 28 hours per week if I'm a
full-time student that's about how much
time a full-time student spends studying
in the United States according to
studies that I've read you might think
oh well I thought students would
probably be it'd be more like 40 hours
now it turns out that school is not
nearly as hard as everybody pretends it
is and 28 hours is about how much people
spend studying and going to class taking
exams all those different things now
that may vary from major to Major like
if you're studying you know medicine for
example it may be way more intense than
that but uh if you're working let's say
28 hours a week on your studies that's
28 hours of time and energy that you
don't have to devote to
a job that can help you earn income so
let's say that
you're working at a grocery store as a
manager and you're working there you're
making uh you know thirty thousand
dollars a year and that job takes 40
hours out of your week so
you could you could basically have to
bolt on an extra 28 hours per week worth
of work if you're full-time or if you're
doing part-time school it might only be
like half that 14 hours additional study
and it would take you twice as many
years to finish the program but it may
be much more sustainable so to answer
the question of should you go back to
school if you're older It ultimately
comes down to Roi and it comes down to
your own personal feelings about how
much longer you think you're going to be
able to work and whether you think you
could balance going to school with your
current
obligations both familial and work
what if I'm outside the U.S
so
of course I'm very blessed to have been
born in the United States native English
speaker I've got a U.S passport
um and they're only about four percent
of the world population also shares that
privilege
if you were born in China India Nigeria
one of many other countries that receive
many of the 1 million International
students that are studying in the United
States these are people that have
generally finished high school in their
country and then gotten into
uh you know internet they've gotten into
a university here in the US they've
cleared the very lengthy Visa process
maybe their family has saved up for a
generation to be able to afford for them
to be able to go to the United States
and study
if you're one of those people
it can be very tricky and I'm not going
to give like super granular advice for
that but I will say that there may be
some Alternatives that don't involve
going through the Visa process where you
can still graduate from a U.S University
without having uh to spend a huge amount
of money now we're talking about forty
thousand dollars U.S per year to attend
a state school with out-of-state tuition
so by virtue of being outside of the
country you are out of state and in fact
some schools May charge even higher
tuition for international students than
they would charge for like another U.S
resident who is just like from a
different state like let's say I grew up
in Oklahoma if I had studied in Texas
even though it's very close
geographically I would have to pay out
of state tuition which is three times as
much right which really incentivizes you
to go to school in your state so as an
international student you face a whole
lot of additional considerations around
cost
later I'm going to talk about some
Alternatives that can allow you to get
an American Education without spending
American International student prices
or which type of University I go to so
it does matter quite a bit which type of
University you go to and I'll tell you
which one you should go to in a minute
but let me first lay out the the three
big categories so first there's public
and that could be both Community College
and universities that could be like a
State University system it could be just
like the research University Systems for
example in California you have
California State University and you also
have University of California system
then there's private
and that's non-profit private non-profit
so this is usually
private schools small liberal arts
colleges it can also be like all the Ivy
League schools or private most private
universities in the United States are
owned by churches for example
um and then so they may have some you
know required theology related credits
for the undergrad and then there's
what's called private
for-profit so this would be uh the kinds
of universities you see on late night TV
uh basically running commercials uh
there have been so many of these that
have been shut down recently because
frankly you should just assume that
these are scams until proven otherwise
in my opinion and I know there are
probably lots of people out there who
are watching this who work at a private
for-profit and if you're one of the good
ones fantastic but uh I really believe
that these are the only considerations
you should make uh and it may be harder
to get into these institutions there may
be more paperwork there may be less
guidance from a counselor sales person
who's trying to get you in but it is
absolutely best to go to one of these
now
you generally want to go to a community
college first
the reason is twofold one community
colleges are a lot cheaper
they are a lot cheaper they're designed
uh for people who don't necessarily have
a whole lot like a giant scholarship for
playing sports or for academic reasons
they're also designed with uh local like
people who don't want to commute really
far they want to continue living with
their parents or living with a roommate
in the area where they have their job or
if they've already have kids you know
not having to uproot or spend a huge
amount of time on the road basically and
a lot of times the instruction you get
at a community college is actually
better than what you'll get at a
four-year research institution and the
reason is everybody at community
colleges is focused on teaching they're
focused on actually helping the students
learn and they're less focused on trying
to get their H number uh and get more
citations in Academia the other thing
that I'll say about community colleges
in addition to being cheaper and having
you know potentially better pedagogy is
that you can use
your completion of a community college
to transfer into a school that otherwise
might be very selective and difficult to
get into for example I talk to people
all the time who go to a community
college and then are able to transition
like from you know for example uh in
University of Texas pretty
difficult to get into University of
Texas they probably turn away a lot of
people but if you go to a community
college in Texas it's almost like you're
guaranteed to be able to transition in
now this depends from Community College
to Community College I would definitely
research this beforehand but if you plan
to go to uh more selective State
University and when I say State I mean
the same is public a State University
then
Community College can make a lot of
sense so you finish two years at
Community College you transfer in to a
four-year University and you earn your
bachelor's degree you already kind of
have an associate's degree which you can
get through community colleges and some
community colleges may even offer
bachelor's degrees
if you want to stay at a community
college the entire time and get a
bachelor's degree there I don't think
there's any harm should be good return
on investment now the second one is
private uh private non-profit
these are all your Ivy Leagues MIT
Caltech a whole lot of the best
universities in America are private and
that kind of makes sense in the sense
that like they usually have really high
tuition so they're able to pay their
professors a lot more maybe they have a
lot more money to plow into having
fancier campuses things like that they
probably have a lot more money for
activities and things like that
these institutions are often much older
as I said they're they're often owned by
Churches uh the oldest if you want to
know what the most prestigious
universities in the United States are
just stack rank them by their age
Harvard is the oldest university in the
United States and it also happens to be
generally regarded as the best uh you
know Yale Princeton Columbia the other
Ivy League schools are also very old
schools in fact you'd have to go pretty
far down the list before you got to a
prestigious institution that was founded
within the last 100 years right so
you can absolutely go to these private
non-profit universities but they are
expensive they're dramatically more
expensive than going to them paying
in-state tuition you might be spending
something like forty thousand dollars
you might be spending something like
sixty thousand dollars a year just in
tuition and fees to be able to attend
these universities so the ROI you would
think oh well these private non-profits
probably have lower Roi than just
attending a good Public University and
that is true in a lot of cases depending
on what you major in you can go to
Princeton and study liberal arts and get
out and maybe make a lot less money than
somebody who studied computer science at
a public university and spent a small
fraction of what you spent on your
degree
but one thing I will tell you about
these institutions is
the actual major Youth Study is much
more important than where you study
granted that if you just have a generic
degree in anything from Harvard that's
probably
better than having like an engineering
degree from a small state school that
nobody's heard of in terms of immediate
earning potential coming out of college
but that is very quickly
like that difference is very quickly
eroded in the marketplace if you
continue to progress as a software
engineer you can quickly outpace and out
out earn somebody who has an
undergraduate degree from Columbia in
film or something like that right so
don't worry about which school you study
at I would just optimize for Roi unless
you're getting a large scholarship or
you have some sort of like your parents
went to the school and you can get like
a favorable deal going there uh I would
definitely prioritize going to public
schools and I would definitely
prioritize leveraging the Community
College to public university pipeline
so what's the optimal path through
University
if you want to further reduce the cost
of college education if you're in high
school I recommend taking AP credits
you may hear AP Physics AP Computer
Science AP History these can all
potentially be turned into free college
credit uh when you go into the
university you can essentially come into
University with like up to a Year's
worth of college already done imagine
going to college instead of having to
study for four years you come in as a
sophomore and you only have three years
of study you can potentially do that
with ap
advanced placement that's a system we
have here in the United States and you
can take those courses and take those
exams here in the United States uh as a
high school student and even after high
school you might be able to take some of
those but there's another thing that's
very powerful that a lot not as many
people know about and that is CLEP clip
uh I don't remember what it stands for
I'm not going to look it up it doesn't
matter everybody just calls the clip and
what it is you clip out of courses you
take an exam you can read books you can
do whatever you want if you already have
some knowledge of a subject just from
being casually interested in it you may
be able to pay 120 take the CLEP exam
and then you don't have to take that
course in University so a lot of what we
call gen Ed general education credits
like history like philosophy like um
physics you may have to take these
courses depending on which university
you study at but if you CLEP out of
those courses you may not have to take
them at all you can save a ton of money
and you can also save a lot of time
because it may turn out that like
sitting there like with the professor
who's distracted with their you know
research and doesn't even really care
about teaching uh it may be like a
really not every College course is
amazing that's one thing I'll tell you
about of course about college is you may
be shocked at how low quality the
product is for what you're paying for I
had a friend who was studying at NYU and
she was paying seven thousand dollars
per course
if you're paying seven thousand dollars
this course is better to be pretty damn
good if it's really just like one
semester's worth of sitting among a
whole bunch of other people in an
auditorium learning from the professor
right and frankly not all of them are
and in a lot of cases it is good to clip
out of courses
so there are what I like to call Ultra
low-cost
Ultra
low cost
views these are universities that are so
much cheaper that it's like almost
unfathomably cheap and there are two
that I really want to talk about which
is University of the people
and then there's uh Western Governors
University now I should add we do not
have any sort of affiliate relationships
with these institutions nobody from them
is telling me like oh please Quincy
create a video where you pitch our
universities I'm just saying in terms of
sheer Roi these are a slam dunk
especially if you're going to be working
if you're not going to be able to attend
a campus if you're a non-traditional
student meaning you're like older than
25 you're going back to get your degree
you're probably going to be doing what
we call night school uh working at
essentially remotely learning so in
those cases it 100 makes sense to
consider University of people or what
Western Governors University in fact I
have lots of friends who've attend both
of these universities so I can
personally vouch that you know it's a
degree now uh let me tell you how these
work so
they both work different ways University
of the people
you just pay an assessment fee for each
course it's technically tuition free and
so you'll pay I think 120 to take the
exam at the end of each course and
there's 40 courses so you multiply
40 courses times 120 we can do that
right here uh 40 times 120
you get uh uh 480 4 800.
imagine getting a degree
from an accredited four-year University
for less than five thousand dollars
it sounds too good to be true but it's
true it's real I have lots of friends
who've done it uh Western Governors
University
uses a slightly different system where
you can basically take as many courses
as you want per semester and I think
it's it's less than ten thousand dollars
to do an entire year there and if you
work really aggressively you can
potentially complete an entire degree in
like a year 18 months so you could be
spending uh you know fifteen thousand
ten thousand dollars and get a full
accredited four-year degree
how does accreditation work
accreditation is essentially how
universities police one another to make
sure that they're not cutting corners
and it is kind of a peer review system
you'll have professors from one
University go and visit another
University and bless that program so
there are several different kinds of
accreditation there's what's called
Regional
there's what's called uh National
and then there's what's called
programmatic
the way that the most prestigious is
regional that may sound like huh well
that's weird why would Regional be more
uh you know heavy in value than National
but it's much harder to get Regional so
there's this organization called
c-h-e-a the Council of Higher Education
accreditation I think uh assessment or
something like that I can't remember the
exact acronym but uh this is the
organization that blesses universities
and if you can get this accreditation
it's worth its weight in gold
essentially it's it's like everybody
will take your University seriously and
you don't need to worry about being
called a quote-unquote diploma Mill now
people throw that term diploma Mill
around all the time and I just want to
give credit to the universities like
a diploma Mill I consider that to be
basically some place where you you mail
in and you get a fake PHD right and you
don't actually do any coursework there
are plenty of programs like that that
are super sketchy uh never associate
yourself with any of those uh if you are
found to have like a fake degree of any
kind it's career suicide essentially
don't do that
but
uh there are also organizations that
don't quite rise to that level of rigor
but are totally legit
national accreditation
so this is like a lot of the private
for-profit universities get national
accreditation is a little bit easier and
for example uh both of those
universities I talked to about earlier
University the people Western Governors
universities they get national
accreditation and this includes
something like depart it's called
um uh deac accreditation
this is like Regional uh distance
education accreditation commission I
believe so
um you might be able to get deac
accreditation which is a form of
national accreditation and if you get
that then you're basically a remote
school that can be online it's very very
common uh I think both University of
people and Western Governor each
University started off with that
accreditation and then moved to national
accreditation or regional accreditation
over time there's a third type of
accreditation called programmatic
accreditation programmatic is if you're
a nursing school you're a law school
you're a medical school you're doing a
specific program and you just want that
specific program accredited now Business
Schools are like certain types of
accreditation that are more prestigious
in Business Schools you can check
uh this is a good measure to make sure
you're not getting ripped off as a
student but one thing I want you to keep
in mind is you can be like a total
terrible University and still
technically be accredited it's very hard
to lose your accreditation it rarely
happens so you University might be good
at one point have get accredited and
then may have a succession of leadership
that kind of like uh strips the
university for parts or Cuts lots of
corners and it could take decades for
that University to lose this
accreditation despite the fact that
they've essentially been asleep at the
wheel in terms of running that
University so do not look to
accreditation as the sole Arbiter of
whether a university is good what I
recommend is reach out to the alumni you
know hang out at an alumni function if
people are like man I'm so glad I
studied at the school like I've had this
amazing career and I attribute if people
are like donating tons of money to the
school that's like a really good
indication that it is a good school so
even though you understand now that I've
given you this mini lecture on
accreditation just don't take it as
you know
it has some face value but don't make
accreditation be your shortcut to
deciding oh the school's cool
investigate you your education may very
well be the second largest investment in
your life presuming that you are able to
afford enough money to buy a home here
in the United States uh which is
probably going to be bigger than your
education unless you go to a really
expensive school so just treat this as
it's the second biggest investment in
your life one other thing I'll say is
aside from transferring between
community colleges and four-year
institutions it's very hard to transfer
credit you don't want to make the wrong
decision go to a bad University have to
switch a lot of the money you've spent
will just basically be gone you might be
able to transfer in like a few classes
but you're probably gonna have to retake
a lot of those so you definitely want to
do your research and pick the right
School
first and don't just pick the school
that's like really close down the road
even if it's like a private for-profit
or a private non-profit that charges an
arm and a leg really drill into those
outcomes and make sure that you're
making a good decision as far as Roi
again above all else if you're trying to
get your money's worth consider the
return on investment
what are some traps people fall into
so there are several traps that people
fall into uh one I will call the passion
trap
passion
so
you really like taking photos you really
want to go to school for photography and
become a professional photographer
that is totally chill I encourage you to
pursue that passion but I would not
encourage you to attend a private
for-profit photography school for
example or even a private non-profit
photography School in fact I wouldn't
necessarily encourage you to pursue
photography as a major at all I would
consider I would encourage you to
continue to study uh you know looking at
professional photographers studying
their work studying other things because
if you get a major in photography it
doesn't really matter for most gigs that
you're gonna be working as a
photographer it's not like the the uh
person's gonna be like oh where did you
study they're gonna be like show me your
portfolio show me your work or who
recommended you those kinds of things
there are certain Fields where a college
degree doesn't really matter unless
you're trying to become a professor in
that field and I will tell you that
Academia is very dysfunctional we call
it the
uh academic pyramid scheme for every PhD
uh for every uh tenure track uh we'll
just call this tenure
in the US there are 50 x
phds trying to get up there right trying
to climb the pyramid to get to the top
it's very difficult to get this coveted
tenure track position at a university so
Academia don't play that game like
unless you're really confident or you're
just studying a field where you're going
to want to get a PhD anyway like physics
I would not continue to study I think so
many people spend years studying their
PHD before they realize man I really
don't like this and they turn out a PhD
program so anyway I know this isn't
about PHD programs but I'll just take
this moment to tell you that
Academia is kind of a pyramid scheme and
everybody kind of knows it and they play
the game anyway because it's like
playing the lottery if you get that
tenure track position if you're able to
live that life of mind and be a
professor and do cool interesting
research
you're going to meet lots of professors
who are like oh of course like it's
worth it I had a great time it's not
that big it's not a pyramid scheme but
keep in mind that for every person who
entered into a PhD program hopefully
trying to become an academic there are
49 other people who did not make it
right so just just keep that in mind
so that's trap number one trap number
two
would be micromanaging
so
you're going to look at U.S news world
report and you're going to see all of
these data everywhere oh my goodness
there's so much data like I'm gonna be
the most informed I'm gonna make the
most educated decision anybody's ever
made about where to study and I will
tell you none of that stuff really
matters that much those data are
probably spurious at best because
they're not taking into account a whole
lot of different things like the
socioeconomic background or the people
who studied at that school
of course people at Ivy League schools
generally have better outcomes because
their parents are probably rich in the
best predictor of your own success is
how successful your parents were
you know don't don't hate the player
hate the game as I like to say like I'm
not trying to pick on specific
universities but I'm just saying uh of
course if you drill into the information
in I think this is a Neurosis you've got
in countries like India and China you've
got people that are studying extremely
hard to try to get into this coveted
like top tier of universities thinking
that's the only path forward like I've
got to get into Harvard I've got to get
into MIT but I'm here to tell you if you
study at a good state school and you
study hard and you go out and you get a
good job and you continue to progress
through your field you can be in as good
or better position than those people
that work so hard to get into these
extremely selective institutions so that
would be what I call the micromanagement
uh trap don't think that just because
the data say oh you should go to Harvard
never get that kind of Harvard or bus
mentality look at other options
so I think that this kind of breaks down
when you're looking at good public
institutions because they are much more
reasonably priced
you're much more likely to have a higher
Roi so the third trap is I see people
think like
uh I don't care about money
right like I was like this I uh worked
at Taco Bell I worked construction I
worked at grocery stores I worked at
convenience stores I just did odd jobs
and I read books and I just hung out and
I was totally cool with that uh and I
didn't care about University because I
didn't care about money like so many of
the best things in life were completely
free hanging out uh with your friends
reading books going for a walk in the
park and it can be very easy to think
like oh minimum wage is fine uh I'll
just make do I I can sleep on a on a
mattress on the floor and I can have my
bookshelf made out of concrete blocks
and it's totally chill
I'm here to tell you that that is a
totally viable strategy to get you
through your 20s maybe even your 30s but
if you have a kid if you get diagnosed
with type 2 diabetes if you find out
that uh your parents are you know have
cancer any number of different things
that can come up the U.S Health Care
system is not going to save you U.S
welfare system is practically
non-existent you are going to be screwed
really badly if you don't plan ahead and
the best way to plan ahead is to make
money even if you're living well below
your means
and I can tell you I know lots of people
who make lots of money as software
Engineers who do not drive Ferraris and
do not have you know Park Avenue
Apartments uh they are living well
within their means and they're just
taking that money and they're putting it
into an index fund and they're just
letting compound interest the most
powerful force in the universe according
to Albert Einstein compound interest put
some money into the stock market in a
sensible way again I just recommend
index funds because there's no
management cost really it's like
negligible it's like four or five basis
points and just let that money sit there
and you know let it do dollar cost
averaging if you want where every day it
takes out like a certain amount of money
so you don't have to think about it and
just earn that money and then if you
ever need it you have a whole lot of
money there
why not there's never a situation where
having a lot of money is worse than not
having money right it is an absolute
advantage in terms of the curveballs
that life can throw your way so I just
want to emphasize that even if you don't
care about money it is a rational thing
to go to college and try to maximize
your earning power so that if if you
don't care about money and you can push
a broom as a janitor uh which I did uh
you know push a mop Around clean up the
grocery store or you could be just doing
some knowledge worker job that pays
twice as much that isn't significantly
more exerting mentally or physically and
just accruing money that you know you'll
have in case you need it so I genuinely
believe that like take this I don't care
about money thing it's I know it can
sound cool like uh to just be aloof and
not care and stuff like that but at the
end of the day it is a very good thing
to have money I'm not saying you need to
become you know 100 millionaire or
anything like that I'm just saying to
become middle class and to to save money
and to reduce your your risk later in
life and it would be very cool to retire
at some point right you may not think
like oh I love working I don't think
I'll ever need to retire but you may
very well change your mind when you're
getting older or you get diagnosed with
repetitive stress syndrome where you're
having insomnia because your sleep's
broken down over the years or you're
experiencing vertigo or any number of
different things that can just suddenly
come out of nowhere and start making it
much harder to work
so uh these would be I think my three
traps just to recap
studying what you're passionate about as
opposed to studying something that has a
higher Roi as I've established computer
science has the highest Roi I don't
think that's going to change anytime
soon
micromanaging your studies and focusing
too much on data and not seeing the
force for the trees
and not thinking that college is
important and not planning for the
future I think as long as you avoid
these three traps you're going to find
yourself in a much better situation and
you're going to incur a lot less risk
and you're probably going to incur a lot
less debt
drop out
so a lot of entrepreneurs drop out of
college but not a lot of entrepreneurs
succeed of course Bill Gates
uh Mark Zuckerberg
you can probably think of lots of famous
people who've dropped out of school and
then gone on to become billionaires and
the thing to note about that is
they are allies just by virtue of their
extreme success they're already outliers
but in practice like we looked at the
I'll show it again the Fortune 500 CEOs
I think virtually every one of these
CEOs has a degree there are sometimes
companies that are founded by people who
drop out of college uh but it's much
less common now I'm going to tell you
right now there's a Trope uh the the uh
you can get a job without a degree right
like Google
um Apple
you know all all these companies coming
out and saying you don't need to you
don't need a degree to work here anymore
but
I challenge you to walk around the
Googleplex or the Apple campus and ask
people like hey do you have a degree do
you have a degree you might walk around
all day without finding somebody who
doesn't have a degree yes technically
you can get a job at Apple if you don't
have a degree you can get a job at
Google if you don't have a degree but
you probably need to be some open source
Superstar or you need to have like 10
years of sysadmin experience uh there
are so many ways that you can get good
enough at software development that you
could work at a big tech company without
a degree but it's rare that somebody
just gets hired straight out of high
school into such a role because getting
a degree first of all it shows that you
have the fortitude to actually finish
the degree which is not easy and two it
shows that you think long term and that
you've made that investment in yourself
and three it's just like a general way
of de-risking people and almost every
one of these companies regardless of
what they say publicly they're going to
have an HR department and they're going
to list maybe they don't put the
University degree requirement in their
job sourcing but I guarantee you that
the HR people that use filtering
software that's going to be one of the
factors that they look at when they
determine which resumes to review which
people to interview it's it's probably
going to be weighted maybe the degree is
only worth like three or four points out
of like 20 points that they would
consider but it is you know a
consideration and I will tell you like
freecoat Camp I think we have probably
at least
five or six people on our team of 35
people who do not have a University
degree but we also have several people
who have phds right so it like
educational me
it depends so much on the individual
there are so many considerations but
free code Camp is one of the most
adventurous institutions in terms of
hiring people who don't have University
degrees for coveted remote knowledge
worker jobs
practice most companies are going to be
much more careful about that so if you
drop out because your company is getting
millions of dollars in seed funding or
you've gotten a whole bunch of clients
and you don't feel like you need to go
to school anymore that is totally
legitimate I can totally see why if your
career is taking off and college is a
distraction you can drop out and in fact
some institutions like Stanford have
like a rule that like you can basically
come back anytime you want and just pick
back up your studies other institutions
if you're gone for a certain number of
years your credit's kind of expire and
you have to start at the beginning right
so you'll want to look at those
considerations but really unless you're
you're getting some sort of crazy
product Market fit some sort of crazy
traction with your startup or unless
some really rich person like offered you
a job to like be their kind of personal
assistant or to build some product for
them or something like that I would not
leave college for that now
again if you study at Stanford or if you
study at a university that's more
permissive and porous as far as coming
in and out you could take a gap year
that's totally fine but I would
recommend at some point going back and
completing your degree even if that's
just to to go and completely agree at uh
University the people or Western
Governors University
so as you can tell I'm very much in the
college degree is important Camp you're
not going to see me trashing college
degree or or running Google ads to say
like hey you don't need a degree just go
to a free code camp I don't believe that
at all I believe very much in the
benefit of a college education I myself
have a college education I even went to
grad school most of my friends went to
college I whenever you hear some wealthy
person say oh you don't need to go to
college anymore
just ask yourself does that person have
a college degree like can they really
say that objectively uh because a lot of
times people forget all the things that
they learned in college that did help
them or they don't see the invisible
benefit of just having HR people not
filter you out because you don't have a
degree and getting so many more job
interviews and things like that so I
believe so strongly that everybody
should get a degree and I believe that
most people who are going to school
today should probably get a degree in
computer science because it's so
flexible it's the Swiss army knife of
tech degrees what about free code camps
degree program
I'm very hardened at the ultra low-cost
universities that I was talking about
earlier University of the people Western
Governors University and how they've
dramatically reduced the cost of being
able to get an accredited U.S University
degree
I don't think that they've done enough I
think education wants to be free it
wants for everybody to be able to
benefit from it and if you really want
to make something that everybody could
benefit from you need to make it free
think about the 60 of people on Earth
who live off less than ten dollars a day
think about all the people who are
outside the United States who are not
likely to be able to save up enough
money to come to the US who are not
likely to be able to get a U.S visa who
are living in uh rural Village in India
who are doing subsistence farming in a
rural China uh Chinese town or you know
living in a favela in Brazil those
people those families they're not going
to be able to send their learner their
kids to learn in the United States but
you know what they might be able to do
six
they might be able to do free code Camp
so we're developing a 40 course
undergraduate degree so it's a an
associate's degree in mathematics and a
bachelor's degree in computer science
and it will take you through everything
you need there are no electives there
are no prerequisites you just start at
the top and you progress through these
40 university courses and it's going to
be a whole lot of course work it's going
to take several years for most people if
they're learning part-time but they'll
be able to do it at their own pace for
free they'll be able to work through all
the labs they'll be able to take all the
final exams and they'll be able to get a
degree from a university that will
eventually be accredited it will take
until the early 2030s to finish
developing all these courses we've
already published one of them and we're
going to be publishing a lot more soon
and then after we publish the entire
degree people have gone through the
program gotten the degree it'll still
take some time for us to have enough
longitudinal data to be able to get
accredited by one of the big national
accreditation agencies but that is what
we've committed to and we're making
steady progress toward it I think it's
absolutely vital that we teach the
correct
current skills so you're going to see
not only that we teach eight courses of
engineering math which I think
mathematics is incredibly important
especially if you want to get into like
machine learning
we also want to teach security we want
to teach ethics we want to teach a whole
lot of General Ed credit University
would traditionally have epistemology
topics like that and we want to teach it
in a way that you can progress get an
associate degree halfway through and
then you can progress if you'd like and
get the full bachelor's degree at the
end
our thinking is we want the most middle
of the road conventional University
degree we can we've looked at the top 20
computer science degree programs in the
United States MIT Caltech Harvey Mudd uh
Stanford we've looked at how their
universities are configured in terms of
the the courses that people take as part
of their degree programs and we've
essentially made a composite degree that
hits all those highlights and and it's
again it's the most middle of the road
computer science degree you can imagine
if you're just looking at top
universities that are likely to turn out
graduates who are likely to work in
Industry at Big Tech or potentially get
jobs
at you know Banks
hospitals lots of Developer jobs about
two-thirds of software developer jobs
are not in big Tech they're in other
ancillary Industries and also of course
many of those people that study Those
computer science programs go on to found
startups to get Venture Capital funding
or to be able to bootstrap to success
and so we're going to be focused on just
giving people the skills that they'll
have the optionality to work freelance
to work in big Tech to work at a smaller
Regional company or to potentially build
a startup
what determines job compensation
right so compensation how much money
you're making for your time that you and
that's a way to think of getting
compensated essentially you're selling
your time to an employer they're paying
you for that time it's a it's a buying
and selling process right so of course
first is just labor market economics you
know you have your supply
you have your demand and then you have
your price here in the middle right
so
it depends a lot on what the market is
like in terms of the overall economy and
things like that if there are a lot more
people that are looking for jobs than
there are jobs available employers can
afford to pay less and things like that
so just keep in mind like economics
right that's that's one two skills
so
one of the reasons that doctors get paid
so much money in the United States is
because it takes a lot of work to become
a doctor after you finish High School
you've got to go to college then you
have to get into medical school that's
another four years then after you finish
medical school you have to do three to
five years of residency where you work
with other Physicians and basically are
supervised and then you can become like
fully cool to go start your own practice
or work for a big hospital chain or
whatever you want to do as an
independent physician so if you think
about that that's so much additional
it's like 12 extra years of education
that you need to get before you can do
it to build up those skills so naturally
you're going to want to be compensated
more and so Physicians tend to be
compensated more software engineering
same way you have to study computer
science and you have to like build up
your skills improve your skills but if
the difference between like a developer
who just got out
um and maybe is making like 50 60 70 000
as a software engineer and an engineer
that's working on like recommendation
algorithms at Google they I mean they
could just be an engineer without any
charges people who are working under
them they could be an in ic an uh
individual contributor and they could be
making a million dollars a year in
compensation as a software engineer
right and it comes down to skills and
their ability
three working conditions
so let's think about uh working in what
would traditionally be called a
sweatshop like you might be in
circumstances that are literally illegal
doing piece work having a boss who's
learning over you having dangerous
machines that you're you're like a loom
or a sewing machine or something like
that that you can get hurt on right
to some extent by uh you know getting
better working conditions being able to
work in an air-conditioned office or
being able to work at home as a remote
worker like those are kind of forms of
compensation and often that like your
conversation will be slightly lower if
you have like a posh situation where you
can you know be sitting down all day for
example and then four of course Danger
so the most dangerous jobs in the United
States are working as a lumberjack
working on cell phone towers where you
could potentially fall to your death if
there's a mistake uh there are so many
different uh jobs that you get
compensated because they know that you
could physically get injured or killed
doing the job being a trucker is a very
dangerous job and it's very demanding
physically to be sitting there all day I
mean it's wearing out your back uh you
may have to have a lot of sleepless
nights to deliver your load on time so
those four things all determine
compensation to an extent but the one
thing that you had the most control over
you can't really control this at all
working conditions you just need a
certain floor for your working
conditions and you're probably good some
people might be willing to work in more
hostile conditions like let's say going
and working in a war zone or something
like that to increase your conversation
again that also kind of feeds into
danger a little bit but really what can
you control you can control your skills
and that's probably the the most
rational thing to optimize is trying to
get as high skilled as possible and
that's why I would encourage people to
learn software engineering and
programming because it's a very
remunerative skill set to have
so first I want to say thank you for
hearing me out for listening to my
opinions on a lot of these different
things I hope they're relevant to you I
want to encourage you to continue
developing skills you don't have to go
to university to to fill in these skills
you certainly don't have to go back to
University and get a master's degree and
we didn't really even talk about
Master's degrees I do have a master's
degree I have an MBA I have a lot of
friends who have master's degrees in
general I'll pull up the chart again
in general you do make more compensation
for getting a master's degree but if you
look at the difference between having a
bachelor's degree having a master's
degree and having a bachelor's degree
and no degree it's dramatic like you've
doubled your income for getting a
master's degree and you maybe like get
an extra 10 15 of income if you get a
master's degree depending on what you
get the master's degree in uh you may be
able to get somebody to pay to send you
back to get a master's degree later in
life like your employer might do that as
a perk and say oh we'll pay for you to
get an MBA or we'll pay for you to get a
master's in computer science if you can
do that go for it I think it's great if
you're not going to pay for it but I
don't think the ROI is necessarily there
so I would encourage you to continue to
learn your skills through free code Camp
one question that we didn't get into is
if you already have a University degree
should you go back and get a second
undergraduate degree and I would say in
like 99 of cases that's not worth it
just learn to code on your own
self-teach there are literally millions
of people who are self-teaching there
are tens of thousands of people that I
know know of who I've directly confirmed
have gotten their first software
development job after finishing free
code camp and many of those people did
not have a degree also I'll tell you
that if you listen to the free code Camp
podcast which I host each week just go
in your podcast player of choice and
search free code camp and you'll find my
podcast I talk to a lot of people who
don't have University degrees who are
doing just fine as software Engineers so
everything I've said here there are
always exceptions I think in terms of
maximizing your likelihood of being able
to earn a living to provide for your
family to have a clear forward
and upward career trajectory
getting an undergraduate degree is the
correct thing to do I think getting it
as inexpensively as you as you can
doing in-state tuition doing community
college clapping and AP crediting out of
certain courses or doing an ultra low
cost for your University I think
anything you can do to reduce your cost
is by definition going to increase your
Roi and any money you can save today and
invest is going to compound over time so
really in my opinion it I just recommend
going to the cheapest state school you
can go to that's reasonably good and I
strongly recommend studying computer
science over other Majors just because
as I said it's the Swiss army knife of
undergraduate University degrees so with
that I hope this course has been helpful
for you I hope you've learned a lot if
you're not familiar with the free code
cam Channel we've got tons of amazing
courses like more than a thousand
courses on very specific Technologies
they're not usually some dude standing
at a whiteboard talking a whole lot
usually they're interactive coding
sessions uh but I think you'll find them
to be very helpful just remember that
you don't have to pay a penny to learn
to code you don't need to have a credit
card you don't need to get a visa to
come to the U.S to work at these
hollowed Halls of these big tech
companies or anything like that you
don't need to go to a 400 year old
University to be educated right you can
educate yourself
you can learn whatever you need going to
freecoat camp and using other free
learning resources using other videos
here on YouTube there are so many
amazing teachers here that will teach
you everything you need to know and you
just have to be curious and you just
have to put in the time and the energy
to learn with that
happy coding